johanna wokalek auto und die mit ihrer
kritik
und was haben sie sich bei ihrem mann
verliebt er war ein netter mann damals
damals bis heute
[Musik]
als sogenanntes ferienabenteuer hat sie
angefangen diese liebesgeschichte ein
jahr später wurde er facebook die
verlobung bekanntgegeben
nach zwei weiteren jahren die heirat
[Musik]
dann kam polly nein ihr leben allerdings
nicht für lange
denn die kest griff ein
[Musik]
sollte petric der aus
sind die kaust helden und haben ihre
tochter vor der kest gerettet oder muss
eine marina viel mehr leid tun
darum geht es in diesem film
matschie kost ist nach einem kurzen
abstecher in die schweiz wieder hier wo
sie aufgewachsen ist in einem
abgelegenen küstendorf namens gaia und
der philippinischen provinz leute und
das feuer brennt mit touristen die
ursprünglichen philippinen nützen
fröhlich deswegen es wer tanzt das wäre
viel gast manchmal aber betrunken von
der cas habe ich hier noch niemand etwas
gehört und das sei auch gut so sagt kost
der us kritiker dieser behörde
schweizweit bekommt wurde
[Musik]
die kinder seien hier freilich sagt kost
wuchsen aber glücklich aus so wie es
auch bei uns einmal gewesen sei damals
vor der caspar
soviel gotthelf das gibt es heute
offenbar nur noch in südostasien
die meisten einheimischen wollen indes
nur eines möglichst schnell weg aus
diesem paradies
[Musik]
weil es hier keine arbeit gibt
hier kann man sich seinen
lebensunterhalt nicht verdienen
christian kost ist ihr so etwas wie ein
sechser im lotto
von einem mann aus dem westen der
regelmäßig geld schickt träumen viele
pro monat überweist er tausend franken
das ist hier ein kleines vermögen einen
großen teil davon verwendet seine frau
um ein haus zu bauen
[Musik]
das einzige was mir sorgen bereitet sind
die kleinen risse im beton welche risse
das ist nicht wirklich gut her
aja risse hin oder her hier will er
künftig seine winter verbringen und in
den restlichen neun monaten in der
schweiz klimaanlagen montieren und
warten endlich ist es fertig das gab so
viel zu tun und hat so viel gekostet
8000 franken nur für diese decken
sie haben der cas ein schnippchen
geschlagen aber ein sieg sieht anders
aus
die tochter von christian kost wird
weitgehend ohne ihren vater aufwachsen
außerdem sitzen sie und ihre mutter auf
den philippinen fest
kämen sie zurück in die schweiz wird die
kesse sofort wieder aktiv
dabei hatte ist so hoffnungsvoll
angefangen matschie kost hatte große
pläne
mein traum war es zu arbeiten
aber dann habe ich ein baby bekommen
[Musik]
eine darum musste ich lange warten bis
ich arbeiten gehen könnte ihr plan
schnell viel geld zu verdienen ging
nicht auf
und auch die integration fiel ihr schwer
anders als hier gibt es in der schweiz
eine sogenannte elterliche sorge hier
ist es dagegen normal dass die kinder
unter ihresgleichen aufwachsen sobald
sie richtig laufen können gehen ihre
eigenen wege
dass die eltern stets ein wachsames auge
auf sie haben sie behüten und erziehen
sollten davon hat ihn noch keiner etwas
gehört wenn die dreijährige alle china
allein einen ausflug ins offene meer
macht steht aus hier niemanden
[Musik]
in der schweiz wurden die kostüme
rauschen sitzen direkt am rhein gelegen
maxi cast holte quincy bell nach ein
kind aus einer früheren beziehung
seine frau habe gemeint hieß es wie auf
den philippinen nachbarn fiel auf dass
die kost kinder damals sechs und zwei
immer wieder allein unterwegs waren
auch in der nähe des rheins wir haben
vor problemen für dann habe ich mehr
unterstützung gewünscht und vielleicht
wollt dass das case bei molo vds klopft
und seit weil kraft so ist es bei uns
also irgendwie eher wenige shows
freiburg weil auf mehrheit cdu aber
nicht los dass amon mit dem kloster so
nicht hinter wichtiges auch head of mit
lust oder last war eines der
hauptprobleme der seine frau starke
unterleibsschmerzen hatte die lange
nicht als entzündung erkannt wurden
sie sei oft gereizt und mit den kindern
überfordert gewesen
darum habe er die familienberatung um
hilfe gebeten keine zeit habe man ihm
dort mitgeteilt
erst als die nachbarn alarm schlugen kam
die kest vorbei und fand die überreste
eines vorbildlichen streits vor
meine frau ist okay gestellt wird und
die symptome klagen oder wie muss man
sich das vorstellen
[Musik]
die kest reagierte sofort und brachte
die kinder ins heim
[Musik]
ursächlich für die unterbringung waren
nebst der gesundheitlichen situation von
matschie cast welche die betreuung von
alina und queens rebellen nicht mehr
verlässlich wahrnehmen konnte auch die
vorherrschenden zustände im familienheim
zertrümmerte und herumliegende haushalt
gegenstände sowie spielsachen
angespannte paar problematik häusliche
gewalt die sich für junge kinder
gefährlich und unzumutbar zeigten dass
die kerb intervenierte versteht kost
aber er hätte sich eine lösung im
religiösen umfeld seiner frau gewünscht
eine frage die philippinen und thailand
5 liter hemi helfer der mir war bereit
das wort rhodos sind sogar die ganze
woche bei uns sei ein fatales sowie
trend im heim und doch mit orchester
diskutieren
das hat natürlich noch der spanier führt
in unserer patienten und menschen sollen
eine abwärtsspirale in hennigsdorf sorge
und hoffnung dass man kinder jemals
drucker bekommt wird natürlich immer
wieder kleine oder
und sozusagen der höhepunkt von der
abwärtsspirale zu physischen komisch ja
sicher sicher vor einer rückkehr der
kinder sollte lag es unter anderem
sichergestellt sein dass matschie kost
über längere zeit psychisch und
körperlich stabil ist dass christian
kost regelmäßig beratungsgespräche bei
der anlaufstelle gegen häusliche gewalt
in anspruch genommen hat und dass die
parksituation geklärt und beständig ist
der rest der geschichte ist bekannt
erst brachte die mädchen anlässlich
eines besuchs termins nicht wie
abgemacht in einen kletterpark sondern
um den flughafen wo sie mit ihrer mutter
in richtung philippinen abflogen kaarst
wurde zur nationalen medien figur und
eine der galionsfiguren der testgegner
julia onken meinte zum beispiel das
drama zeigt einmal mehr dass dieses
konstrukt test nicht in der lage ist die
große aufgabe zu bewältigen und pirmin
schwander sagte das tv kost kein
einzelfall sei
[Musik]
rost hatte plötzlich 1500 facebook
freunde und polemisierte weiter baut
nicht mehr nur gegen die cavs sondern
gegen aus mögliche social lieber zb
schreie mich heißer in zürich born to
africa aber die rumlungern sommaruga
gäste einfach nur noch sein
ich arbeite noch bis 70 damit die
rumlungern können es nicht ein
widerspruch dass sie selber in russland
für rote handelt dann zu kritisch sind
geburtsland sie haben wir nicht
verstanden ich bin nicht kritisch gegen
russland und ich an ihre bisherigen
ausland
[Musik]
ein anderer maus schrieb er die antwort
auf die invasion liegt rechts der svp
dazu ein lied der band amok gehört zur
neonazi-szene letztes jahr trat die band
bei einem konzert in unterwasser auf wo
5000 neonazis sieg heil brüllten
wieso machen sie dazu weil wir fan das
dorf afrika nie tabus klar dass der
kandidat für wodka und wenn wir die
zeitlose das in die bürgerrechte und
mädels nicht und eine für ältere wo
informiert und süßigkeiten mit toto dann
haben wir sicher vorstellen dass das
kind auf barrikaden statt und zeigt so
wie ich auch selber mehr das macht mir
die musik arts los und mehreren eigene
meinung bilden
ich möchte eine thema glauben was der
ganze mainstream verzapft und viel war
der leber weg sei darauf und als nazis
abgestempelt das ist so wie lena keul
ein ort oder nazi keule und denn dann
dürfen wir danken und man kann sicher
sagen kann man indes dass ksc turbulent
blieb schon bald hoffte er öffentlich
dass die fluchthilfe für frauen kinder
kein fehler gewesen sei die beziehung
erklärt der für beendet und seine frau
schrieb er sei nicht gut genug für sie
das möge sie nicht an ihm
[Musik]
im moment ist die welt wieder in ordnung
und matschie kauft will mir zeigen dass
sie sich sehr wohl um ihre tochter
kümmert ja ab und zu sogar mit dir
spielt leider ist unklar wo sich alina
gerade aufhält
es ist besser eine kess gebe es hier
nicht und braucht es auch nicht sagt
matschie kost aber immerhin so etwas
ähnliches das department of social
welfare entlocken
kurz der spd das dsw die interveniere
allerdings nur im äußersten notfall nur
wenn keiner mehr da ist wenn die eltern
gestorben
aber sicher nicht wenn es verwandte
kinder hier haben keine eltern bei ihren
großeltern
[Musik]
ja das ist hier normal
natürlich auch hier im vermeintlichen
paradies gebe es probleme erzählt marc
kast später kinder werden vernachlässigt
misshandelt und missbraucht aber darüber
redet man nicht das sei hier privatsache
und darum geht es auch niemanden etwas
an wie sie ihre kinder erziehen
[Musik]
wow
ihre erste tochter ist von einem
norweger sie heißen und ist heute zwölf
ihre zweite tochter ist von einem
philippino heißt prinzipiell und ist
heute 7
beide väter spielen keine rolle im leben
ihrer kinder der norweger hat kein
interesse der philippinen ist tot
[Musik]
nun gibt es nur noch christian kost und
er ist hier auch sonst gefragt denn er
hat geld ein mann namens dario hat darum
große pläne mit ihm und umgekehrt
vielleicht kann man hier 100 züchter
habt ja du hast gesagt du willst hier
ein netz sparen ja das problem ist wir
haben kein kapital
kein kapital ja um netze zu kaufen
wodurch oder fische ist dagegen
sie sagt zu viel korruption das geld
verschwindet das glaube ich nicht
wenn wir das kapital selber managen dann
wird es wachsen und du entscheidest wie
wir den gewinn teilen diverse details
gilt es allerdings noch zu klären
davon dass der therapie office den dario
gibt züchten will ein süßwasserfisch ist
gar nicht zu reden
post will hier etwas aufbauen damit
seine tochter der einst eine berufliche
perspektive hat was hältst du davon wenn
ich 150 tausend pesos investiere und
tilapia fische und hunger zu züchten
[Musik]
das wäre eine gute investition aber du
musst einen vertrag machen damit du
deinen anteil bekommen
das problem ist dass sie hier keine
disziplin haben die gehen nicht die
trinken lieber als fischen zu gehen
ich glaube nicht dass hier alle hart
trinken sind vielleicht ist das die
zukunft die lava und hunger zu züchten
[Musik]
rutschig in der tat blutiges therapie
investor post denkt bereits weiter
er will auch noch in den tourismus
einsteigen
[Musik]
unser plan ist hier unser material wie
buddy kahl und jetski unterzubringen
vielleicht machen wir im ersten stock
zimmer für touristen
wir haben vielleicht einen oder zwei
touristen im jahr
das ist ein perfekter standort für
tourismus wir werden die ersten sein die
hier investieren
die leute bekommen arbeit es ist ja nur
ein kleines dorf braucht einen guide
wenn man zur insel raus oder wenn man
mit dem pferd unterwegs ist dafür
braucht es vielleicht können wir jobs
hier bringen
in diesem dorf gibt es ja sonst keine
arbeit
[Musik]
immerhin gibt es eine schule im dorf bis
zum alter von zwölf jahren können die
kinder hier gratis lernen dann auch ein
tolles von christian kost ab alle
weitere bildung kostet die meisten
eltern werden sich das nicht leisten
können die kaust schon
[Musik]
bildung kann kost seinen kindern hier
kaufen berufliche perspektiven muss er
ihnen aufzubauen versuchen im schoße
ihrer großen familie sei sie endlich
wieder glücklich sagt matschie kaarst
hier gehöre ich hin die frage ist
allerdings ob auch ihre tochter alina
ihr leben auf den philippinen verbringen
will
wenn sie ihre traumwelt schweiz 2 1 von
10 schweiz aber natürlich erst mit acht
sie
[Musik]
das ist nur schwierig also irgendwie was
man wo sie wird deutschlehrer und ich
weiß ja nie ganz wenig das soll
bewerkstelligen weil ich bin aus rheine
und im jahr dauert
ich rede mit ihrer manchmal tief aber
ich glaube sie verstorben im jetzt
[Musik]
im moment scheint alina glücklich zu
sein aber wird sie es bleiben
irgendwann wird man sie fragen können ob
das alles zu ihrem wohl gewesen ist
[Musik]
landolin mal alt wirklich zum desaster
wird seine dankbar sie gebraucht das hat
jetzt das wahre zukunft zeigen
[Musik]